i'm dominic rosales i work for a family
owned and operated septic company here
in the hill country of texas we
specialize in cleaning and maintaining
both septic and grease traps on
residential and commercial properties
i'm going to show you how we fully
unclog and pump out a septic system
a septic tank contains everything that
exits the house through any wastewater
pipe or drain line that includes the
sinks toilets showers bathtubs and then
what happens is over the years sludge
tends to build up and that requires the
tank to be completely cleaned out to
prevent solids from flowing into the
drain lines of the septic system
so here we have a septic tank that's
being clogged up by a huge quantity of
baby wipes the baby wipes have been
sitting in the septic tank for over
seven years which was the last time the
septic tank was serviced
so whenever you look at a package that
says flushable wipes what they mean is
flushable into city sewer
now i understand this can be misleading
because it does say flushable but you
need to realize that it's not
biodegradable and will remain in your
septic tank until the next septic tank
cleaning
so the first thing i look for when i
pull up to a property are the vent pipes
located on the roof those usually align
with the sewer pipes under the house
which lead to the clean out and then the
septic tank so when we probe and hit the
tank we're able to get a rough estimate
of how deep the actual tank is
and that echo will let us know that
we're in the right spot and that we have
located the tank and then we can start
to dig
so when i open up this septic tank lid
the first thing i notice is a huge clump
of baby wipes when i'm digging up a
septic tank the first side i'm digging
up is the inlet side which contains a
majority of the sludge and that's
usually where the clog is located so the
other side of the septic tank is the
outlet side that side contains mostly
dirty water it rarely contains solids
i use my hose to try and vacuum out the
baby wipes but they're just too thick so
i have to bring out three prong rake i
then use the three prong rake to pull
out all the baby wipes inside of the
septic tank bag them up and then dispose
of them at the local wastewater plant
along with the septic waste which we
pull from the septic tank
we're pumping out the septic tank until
we're able to see the bottom then we'll
rinse the bottom of the septic tank with
the water hose to ensure that it's left
clean for the customer
so once we've reached the bottom of the
septic tank we're going to ask the
customer to flush the toilet to ensure
that everything is exiting the house and
entering the septic tank
people that are on septic systems need
to keep in mind that everything that
enters the septic tank is going to be
there until it's cleaned out besides the
water so if that's grease plastics paper
whatever's not being able to be broken
down by bacteria is going to stay in the
tank permanently
we recommend pumping out septic tanks
every three to five years or based off
the sludge level inside of your tank
if your septic tank does clog there is a
chance that if you do keep running water
and keep flushing everything you're
flushing is not able to exit the home so
it can begin to start coming out of your
toilets or your showers
usually it's the thing that has the most
capacity which is usually the bathtub if
somebody has that